[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT GOODRICH: OK, so
good afternoon, everybody.
My name's Matt Goodrich
and I'm a product manager
on the Android Enterprise team.
It's not always I get the
opportunity to stand up onstage
after a video like that,
which hopefully got you
a bit energized, so thanks
to our marketing team
for putting that together.
What I wanted to do was spend
the next 45 minutes giving you
an overview of what's
new on Android Enterprise
and what's coming up.
Over the last
three or four years
we've made huge strides
in Android's readiness
for enterprise.
I think if you had
just evaluated Android
four years ago,
you probably would
have thought that was maybe
one or two things missing.
But we've been working
really, really hard,
the team's worked very hard o--
I think we can really
now say categorically
that Android is
ready for business.
But before we get
started, I just
want to do a quick
show of hands.
How many of you
feel like you've got
a reasonable understanding
of what Android Enterprise is
at this point?
OK, so maybe a
little under half.
So what we'll do is we'll
spend a little bit of time
to set a bit of the context,
get those of you that
haven't experienced Android
Enterprise so far up to speed
with what the basics
are, and then we'll
talk a bit more about
what's new and next.
So to start with, I really want
to begin with the opportunity
that Android poses
for enterprises.
Not only is Android the
operating system that
runs on your smartphone in
your pocket or the tablet
that you might carry
around in your bag,
it also runs on point of
sales systems, virtual reality
headsets, large screen digital
displays, and even IoT.
So suddenly we've
got a single platform
that covers a wide
range of use cases.
And across all of that we
have the same management
and security capabilities
so you can then manage it,
all of those different devices,
from the same pane of glass.
So your EMM, so your
enterprise mobility manager
or your unified endpoint
management system.
So we've got a huge
opportunity there.
An Android is already a really
prevalent operating system
within the enterprise.
So across over 2
billion Android devices
that they're active
now, globally, there's
about 300 million
devices that are
going to ship to enterprises
this year, according to IDC.
And what you see
in these numbers
is a split between
individually liable devices--
so these might be purchased
personally and then used
for works, so BYOD--
also choose your
own devices, where
employers might provide
devices as part of the employer
benefits.
And Android has
80% of that market.
So quite close to the
consumer market share
of well into the 80%.
So huge need, really,
for enterprises
to think about when
they're offering
BYO programs, like making
sure Android is supported.
In corporate liable,
68% of smart devices
shipped into the enterprise
are running Android.
So that's actually
really interesting,
and if as an enterprise,
you haven't already
approved Android for
use or you're not even
considering Android, then you're
really in the minority now.
And if you think about
the opportunities
that you might be missing out
on from that breadth of devices.
So what we're going
to talk about today
is Android in four
different categories.
So first of all,
we're going to talk
a bit more about devices
to fit your business in all
those different use cases.
We're going to talk about how
our management capabilities, so
very comprehensive
and innovative
in the mobile management space.
We're going to touch a
little bit on security.
But my colleague
Dave [INAUDIBLE]
is actually speaking later,
who will dive into that
in much, much more detail.
And I'll touch a little bit on
some of the other technologies
that we're bringing into
Android, which as enterprises
you can benefit from.
So let's first talk
about the devices.
And I already touched on
just diversity of use cases,
but here you can see
that more explicitly.
So all the way from
the traditional use
cases of smartphones
and tablets through
dedicated devices that
a logistics worker might
use when delivering a package
to ensure real-time delivery
tracking through to shared
devices, when you've
got a shelf of devices that
a worker might take out
at the beginning of the
shift and then put back
at the end of their
shift, and making sure
that we can deal with the
different logins scenarios,
deleting data from the
devices when a user logs out
to make sure you've
got that sort
of ephemerality of user data.
Kiosk devices, embedded points
of sale, digital displays,
they're all kind of more of
the dedicated fixed cases.
Virtual reality is
something that's
a bit of a buzzword
at the moment.
There's lots of talk
about it, but enterprise
is a really interesting
use case for that.
We're seeing companies go in
and have more immersive training
courses, particularly for field
workers where they've actually
got to experience some of the
situations they might find
themselves in, and
virtual reality
could be a really
interesting opportunity
within the enterprise.
And similarly,
augmented reality when
you're actually in a sort
of field worker scenario
and you need help,
being able to overlay
that against your field
of view rather than
having to look up in a
text document on a tablet,
for example.
And then finally, IoT
is an emerging area.
There's obviously a lot of
presentations here this week
about IoT and how Google Cloud
is getting into that area,
and Android, with the recent
GA launch of Android Things,
is also getting
present in there too.
One of the challenges
we've heard
about the broad range of
devices, though, is that, well,
how do I choose the devices
that I want in my enterprise?
There were over 400 different
manufacturers developing
devices with running
Android, and so navigating
that ecosystem is
really very difficult.
So what we did earlier
this year was we
launched a program called
Android Enterprise Recommended.
What this does is it creates
a higher level of requirements
around things like security,
device capabilities,
and consistency of the user
experience across devices
to make sure that
its easier for IT
decision-makers to decide which
devices to purchase and then
be confident that
those devices have
the longevity and the simplicity
required of an enterprise
environment.
So a lot of that is a
focus is on selection,
but particularly a point which
has been painful in the Android
ecosystem is around updates.
And so what we do with
Android Enterprise Recommended
is that those
devices are required
to have 90-day security
patch updates for three years
after the release
of that device.
And they also have to have
at least one dessert release
update as well.
So that's starting to sort
of push the Android ecosystem
into a more updated mode.
We've already got now
over 40 devices from nine
different manufacturers,
and this just
gives us some examples
of some of the devices
that already ranged.
Now these, you'll
see that these are
all kind of high-end
knowledge work devices.
What we're doing now is
we're working with the OEMs
to also come down the
range of price points
to have a wide range of mid-tier
and lower tier devices as well.
What we're starting
to hear from customers
who are aware of the Android
Enterprise Recommended
program--
sorry, I'll try and get out
of the way so you can see--
is that the list of devices
that we've approved through AER
is actually helping
customers now
select not only the
kinds of devices
that they want to
purchase themselves
as corporate-liable devices,
but also the set of devices
that they're willing to
support as part of a bring
your own device program.
So this was a survey that
we sent out to our customers
just recently.
And really starting to show a
high degree of traction there.
How are we evolving Android
Enterprise recommended?
Well, we're bringing
in new device types.
So we've got a rugged device
program coming in soon, so
a slightly different set
of requirements there.
Things like drop test
requirements coming in.
We're also looking at applying
the principles of Android
Enterprise Recommended to
different partner types,
to the EMM and UEM type vendors,
systems integrators as well,
and they're also
developing programs
for carriers and
developers too so
we can give a degree of
confidence to our customers
that these products and services
have reached a higher bar.
So my colleague Ken
[? Shutt ?] is actually
going to be talking
in the next slot
after this over
the way in Moscone
West in much, much more detail
about all these programs.
So if you want to hear more,
do catch his session later on.
So let's change
gears now and talk
about the comprehensiveness of
Android's management framework.
And the way I want
to start here is
with the range of different
modes of operation
that we have for
Android devices.
So starting on the
left hand side there,
for bring your own device,
we have this concept
called a work profile.
What a work profile does is
it's a separate user, really,
in the Android operating
system, but it's the apps
and the data are shown
to users at the same time
in the launcher,
and they're badged
with the little briefcase
icon there so users
can see whether
they're using the work
app or the personal app.
And you can navigate
between these apps
just as you would any
other two apps personally.
But the benefits are that you
can set policies around how
enterprise data can be shared.
You can switch off
things like copy paste,
or sharing between apps through
the share sheet on apps.
But also a benefit for the user.
The user can be confident
that their personal usage
of their own device isn't
being monitored by their IT
department, and should
they leave the company,
The only thing that the
IT department can delete
is the corporate data,
the work apps and data,
leaving all of their
personal apps and data
entirely untouched.
So benefit actually
for both sides.
It's also now possible
to be able to switch off
the work profile, like on
an evening or a weekend
or when you are on vacation,
which just enhances
that capability to keep
work separate and out
of your personal life.
Then moving onto the
company-owned side of things,
we can also have your
fully managed device which
has a few more capabilities
around things like factory
reset protection, and
being able to control
what Wi-Fi hot spots a
device can attach to,
things are VPN as well.
But also you can add a
work profile to that.
So you still get the benefits
of the data separation,
but if you're a
company that wants
to allow your users to use the
corporate devices personally
and have your employees only
carry around one device, which
is very convenient for
them, then you can certainly
do that in a managed way.
Of course, you can have just
a solely fully managed device
which is corporate-only.
And then we've also got a mode
similar to the fully managed
device, which is what
we call dedicated.
So this is where you can lock
a single or a very small number
of apps to a device, which use
access to things like settings
or recents or
notifications, even,
and so if you've got a device,
for example, for a logistics
worker who wants to focus
solely on delivering
packages or navigating to
their next drop-off point,
then you can do that without any
risk of the user accidentally
or intentionally changing
settings and causing
their device to no longer work.
So a comprehensive set
of different modes,
depending on the
particular use case
that you're trying to roll out.
I want to highlight here just
the length of time and effort
that we've really spent on
building out the feature set
within Android Enterprise.
We started off in Lollipop
with the initial iteration
of the work profile and
the fully managed device,
and have continue to
evolve that over time
through to Android Oreo,
which was, obviously, released
last fall.
And then Android P that we've
got coming out fairly shortly.
I'll talk a little bit more
about that in a minute.
The investment that we've been
making over the four years
has really shone through
in terms of the adoption
that we've seen from
enterprises globally, actually.
This is not just focused
on North America.
We've also seen extensive
deployments in EMEA and JPAC.
And over the last
two years we've
consistently seen
10x growth in that.
So if you're considering now
rolling out Android Enterprise,
you can be confident
that we're here to stay,
because this is really a
high-growth strategic project
from Google.
So let's talk a bit more about
how do we build features in?
What are the principles
by which we are
evolving Android Enterprise?
First of all, we believe that
any modern operating system
should enable a user
to just carry around
a single device for work
and for personal, of course,
if the IT policies allow that.
But if there are cases
where that isn't possible,
we still haven't quite got
our work profile right.
So we will continue to
evolve until we can make sure
that every user who is today
carrying around two devices
can actually just
carry around one.
I already touched a little bit
on the one platform concept,
but it's really,
really crucial that we
allow a single management
capability across all
of those different
use cases, and we
will continue to strive
to make sure that happens.
And then the other
thing is ensuring
that app developers
don't have to build
the same app multiple times
for different container
technologies.
So the work profile is built
into the Android operating
system and will run any app.
There is no need for
any additional SDK
or any kind of app
wrapping that's
historically been required.
So let's talk a little bit
about a number of those things.
And one of the challenges
that we've really
had for a long time now, since
we launched Android Enterprise,
is, well, isn't this
just Samsung Knox?
What's the difference between
Samsung Knox and Android
Enterprise?
And to date, it's
really been a choice
for buyers of Samsung devices,
well, do you enroll into Knox
or do you enroll it
in Android Enterprise?
Well, as of Android
Oreo and Knox 3.0,
those two things are
now coming together.
And now Samsung Knox,
the additional APIs
and capabilities
that Knox brings
is built on top of the
basic Android Enterprise
concepts of fully
managed and work profile.
So when you deploy
Knox you are actually
already deploying
Android Enterprise
with a extra bit on top.
So you no longer
have to make a choice
about what you are deploying.
You could even start
with Android Enterprise
and then upgrade to
Knox at a later date.
So really exciting
convergence story there,
and we continue to work
closely with Samsung to evolve
that relationship further.
You can see more
information from Samsung
about the unification
just there.
Another thing
about one platform,
and if you saw the
previous session
where Mike [? Burr ?] was
hosting a number of partners
and customers just
before this, we've
got an increasing
number of companies
working on dedicated devices.
So here are three
customer examples
of cases where they're
deploying, in some cases, quite
interesting hardware, and then
locking apps to that screen
to focus user
attention on the task
that that equipment
is designed for.
So on the left hand side
here, Marks and Spencer,
which is a very large
retailer in the UK,
deploying dedicated devices
to their shop floor assistants
to really give them real time
information to help customers
with their shopping.
Pitney Bowes was
actually on stage,
I saw, over the way
that just earlier,
who have got a famous
brand here in the US.
They have a product
which is a postage meter.
So you can print postage
labels and things
and pay for the postage
with the device.
But now it's a connected product
actually running Android,
and that's enabled a wide
range of developers and apps
to come onto that platform
to actually extend
the capabilities of a
product that they already
have within the office.
And then Chronopost is a
European logistics company
who have just rolled out
Android devices as well.
And you see by the numbers,
substantial volumes of devices
for all these kinds of sectors.
So I already
mentioned Android P,
and there's certainly
no let up on Android
in terms of the investment
that we're putting in.
And a couple of focus
areas I want to talk about,
we're focusing down on
more dedicated devices,
particularly around things
like shift workers and shared
devices.
So imagine you've got
your factory or warehouse
where you've got shift workers.
They sign out a device at
the beginning of their shift.
They can log in and get
the apps and services
that they need as that
particular individual, right.
They don't need to
worry about getting
the right device for the apps.
The device will adapt to them
if they have different needs.
And we provide that now
natively in the platform.
We're also introducing
a new-- well, slightly
updated user experience
for the work profile
to really help users
better understand
this concept of separation
between the work
and personal apps.
We felt that the
ability to mix and match
the apps across your launcher
in any which way is sometimes
a little
counter-intuitive to users
who don't understand correctly
how the data separation works.
So we're refining that.
The other exciting thing about
Android P is that for the first
time in Androids history, not
only have we launched the beta
program for Google's own
hardware-- of course,
the Pixel--
we've also launched the beta
program for seven other OEMs.
And the reason why that's
been possible this time
is because of investments
we made in Oreo
where we introduced a project
called Project Treble.
You might have heard of that.
It was talked about
a lot in the press
when we launched
at IO last year.
But what I introduced is a
hardware abstraction layer
between all of
the device drivers
and the kernel, versus
the rest of the OS
or the system libraries,
the UI, et cetera.
And what that's meant
is it's much simpler
for the OEMs, the
device manufacturers
to update the operating
system on top of that existing
bought support package
for the lower level code.
And so now is a really,
really good opportunity
to get devices into
your labs to start
testing, really, the latest
functionality, because it's
coming down the pike,
actually, quite a lot quicker
than previous releases.
My colleague James
is actually going
to be talking in a lot more
detail with some demos,
as well, on the new
features in Android P.
So if you're interested in
that, do check that out at 3:15
over in the Metreon.
Let's touch a little
bit on deployment.
So management's all
very well and good,
but unless you can simply
deploy those devices
into an enterprise, you're still
going to have some challenges.
Android has actually got
a choice of different ways
that you can
bootstrap [INAUDIBLE]
and this is particularly focused
on the fully managed kind
of devices.
You can use QR codes or NFC,
for NFC-compatible devices.
You can have a text or token
that's issued by your EMM.
But the most recent
edition, which we introduced
in Android Oreo, is zero touch.
So let's just talk a little
bit about the details
of zero touch.
What this does is it gives you
a completely seamless experience
when unboxing a device.
So you don't have to send
devices down a white glove
service, or have them
pre-enrolled by an IT
administrator.
As soon as a user
unboxes that device,
powers it on, and
connects it to a network--
and if it's a
smartphone, you might
have a Sim in there, which will
just get a network anyway--
then it will automatically
read its configuration
and its enrollment
details from a server
and then immediately download
that managing app, whichever
app it is, for whichever
of your favorite EMM is,
and then it will apply
the policy immediately.
So you're up and
running, really,
in very little time with very
little opportunity for the user
to make mistakes as well.
The other cool
thing about this is
if you were to try and set up
the device without connecting
to a network, of course,
it can't talk to the server
to get its policy, but as soon
as that device does connect
to a network, it goes ah ha.
I should have been involved
in full management,
and forced the user
to factory reset it,
and then go into an
enrollment cycle.
So it's also a little bit of
a kind of theft protection
or protection against
misuse as well.
So just a little bit more
about how that works.
Well, we need to get
cooperation from a number
of different stakeholders.
Now remember here,
we're not just
doing this for one
device manufacturer.
We're doing it for a
whole ecosystem, that
has quite a few challenges.
So first of all, we
need manufacturers
to certify their
solutions with us
and also ensure that they are
putting unique serial numbers
onto devices.
That's actually not always
happened in the past.
So there's some process
assurance that needs to happen.
We work with carriers
and resellers
as sort of the trusted
channel partner
to ensure that when
devices are sold,
they're assigned to the correct
customer within Google's
back end systems to
enforce that enrollment.
Because what we want to avoid
is any sort of device hijacking
after a device is sold.
So we ensure that there.
And then from a
customer perspective,
they can use their EMM then
to apply the correct policy
to that device so that when it
boots into an enrolled state,
it's straight in with
the right settings.
So we've already been
working extensively
with partners in
all of those areas.
So this gives you a sense of
all of those different partners
that support zero touch today.
And we've got more coming soon.
On the manufacturers, there
were a lot of the more dedicated
type devices from companies
like Panasonic, Honeywell,
and Zebra, and there's more EMMs
and carriers in the pipe as,
well, which unfortunately
I can't disclose today.
But you'll see not
just region-specific,
but organizations from around
the world who are participating
in this program.
So we're super excited with the
velocity that we've got there.
I want to switch gears now
to talk about app management.
And what we do with app
management in Android is,
actually, we
leverage Google Play
and then add our
management layer on top
to make sure that IT departments
have full control of what's
going on.
Now the question you're
all saying is, well,
why would I want to
use Google Play, which
is full of games
and lots of stuff,
for managing enterprise apps?
Well the great thing
about Google Play
is it's a huge platform.
It's secure.
It sort of authenticates
the install of these apps
and it makes sure the apps
are appropriately signed.
It has global server
footprint, so we can always
deliver the best
experience to your users
in terms of download
performance,
wherever they are in the world.
It applies patch updates.
So you don't have to download
the same APK over and over
again.
And we also do APK scanning,
which is, of course,
part of our security model.
But if you're thinking
about private apps
or internally developed
apps, well, why would
you want your APKs scanned?
Well, the interesting
thing about private apps
is that very often you're
using third party SDKs.
You might be employing an
agency to build it for you
and you've got no idea what
coding standards they uphold.
So APK scanning not only
scans for bad things
happening around malware.
But also against vulnerable
third party SDKs.
So avoid things like Heartbleed
in OpenSSL, for example.
It also comes with comprehensive
publishing tools, which
you can use for your private
apps, crash and performance
supporting, your other reporting
tools in terms of installs,
it manages updates for
you, and then recently
we just announced at Google IO
this concept of an Android app
bundle where for
different devices,
you might download
different assets.
So let's say you've got
different image densities,
different resolutions of
images assets within your APK.
But what Android App Bundle
does is it selectively
installs just the
assets that are required
for the device that's
being installed,
rather than everything.
And that saves you bandwidth,
it saves you battery life,
and it saves you
storage on the device.
So lots of reasons why Google
Play is a great platform
to build on top of.
And then bring the
management on top of that.
You can then curate
an enterprise store
using, of course, a familiar
user experience for your users.
You can silently
push install apps.
So for example, when
a device is enrolled,
you can push apps
automatically, as soon as
that device boots
up, so that a user is
ready to work immediately.
You can also push
configurations to those apps.
So for example, a VPN app can
be quite complicated to set up.
There's lots of different, quite
technical parameters there.
But you can make
sure a user doesn't
have to worry about that by
sending the configuration
bundle down to the app at
the same time as the install.
I already commented
on the ability
to distribute private apps.
We make sure that
those are logically
separate from any
public apps on Play,
so you can be confident that
they are only distributable
to your employees.
But you can also arrange them
within your enterprise app
store side by side
with public apps,
so an employee
doesn't really have
to worry about whether this is
a private app or a public app.
They just install the apps
that are authorized to them.
And then finally, the
new thing that we've
introduced very recently is
a data processing agreement
as part of our contractual
terms for Managed Google Play.
What that means is that we've
got a contract in place to give
you confidence that we will only
use any data that we collect
for providing the
managed play service,
and not for nothing else.
Recently we've made
some improvements
to Managed Play, of course.
It's now possible to
programmatically publish
private apps, rather
than having to go
into a separate console, which
is the play publishing console.
So there is a short link there
if you want to look at that.
If you want to build that
into your own publishing
tools, for example,
or your development
workflows internally.
There's a new API now to
determine how and when
app updates happen.
So whether you allow
them only over Wi-Fi
or you'll also permit them
over cellular, or not at all.
And you can also do per
device app authorization.
So historically, that was
always done on a user basis.
But if the same user
has a BYO smartphone
and a corporate-owned
tablet, you
might actually
want to offer them
different sets of apps
for that same user
for different
security environments.
And that's now possible.
We're also introducing some
additional UI features.
So this is an embeddable
widget that your EMMs will
be able to embed and
you'd be pleased to know,
if you're using Google Mobile
Management as part of G Suite,
these features are going to come
in as soon as they launch later
on this quarter.
So there'll be a
visual user interface
for publishing
private apps, so it's
part of the same EMM experience
you no longer have to chop
and change between consoles.
We're introducing the concept
of web app publishing.
So you'll be able to push a
web app to the user's launcher
so that they can go straight to
the internet or other web tools
that you might have.
And they're also building a sort
of drag and drop store builder,
so when you're curating
an enterprise app store,
you can actually create
your clusters of apps.
You can place the apps where you
want in a very visual way, drag
and drop, to make it very, very
quick to curate that enterprise
app store and get that
out to your users.
Finally, I want to talk
about the Android Management
API, which is a new API that
we've built that really enables
bespoke solutions
within an enterprise,
or indeed, developers who want
to build device management
into a wider solution.
So maybe you're
building, I don't know,
a meeting room
management product.
But you want to manage those
tablets within the meeting room
as part of the same product.
And actually, Android
Management API
is the best way now
to start doing it.
It's a cloud API, so
rather than having
to build an agent
app on the device,
you can just send
policies over that API.
And so it's much, much simpler
to have a single consistent API
rather than having to build
a agent, talk to Managed Play
separately, send push
notifications separately as
well.
Very, very powerful.
We're updating that
every six weeks.
We have a comprehensive
set of functionality.
Not quite everything that
Android OS offers directly yet,
but we're getting there.
And it's built by the same
team that builds the OS.
So we make sure that we're
implementing the features
exactly the way as
they were designed.
And it's policy-based, so you
don't need to worry about all
of the different
sequence of interactions.
You can set a policy and
then just forget about it.
So I'm actually going to be
talking in much more detail
about that, if
you're interested.
It'll be here tomorrow
afternoon at 4:35.
OK, let's quickly
touch on security.
And Android really takes a
defense in depth approach
to security.
So let's start at the bottom.
On the hardware side, we support
dedicated security hardware,
whether that's a trusted
execution environment as part
of the standard chipset,
which is usually a dedicated
part of the processor
onboard, or indeed
discrete secure
element hardware,
which adds extra tamper
resistance to the product.
And some of the tasks
that can achieve
are, you're first of all
managing authentication
for things like key lock,
managing your encryption keys,
and other very sensitive tasks.
The OS itself is hardened
against potential attack.
So we employ a number of
different technologies
to ensure that.
Things like address
randomisation
to make sure that if a hacker
achieves a particular exploit,
it's much more difficult
to replicate that from one
device to the next.
We, of course, have
the Management APIs,
which can enforce your
management security
policies over the top, and
then Google Play Protect,
which is a always on,
call it a anti-virus
or an anti-malware
product, which always
is adapting to identify
and remove the latest
malware from devices.
So really keeping end
to end protection.
I'm not going to go into
any more detail on security
at this point.
Dave Kleidermacher, who's
the VP of Android security
is going to be presenting
there shortly this afternoon.
So if you're interested in
that, do check that out.
Finally, I want to close with
just the level of innovation
that you benefit from when
you invest in Android.
So this is not necessarily
specific enterprise features,
but many, many different
things going on.
I just want to call out a few.
So I've already touched
on augmented reality,
but if you want to build
some of these cutting edge
experiences, whether that's for
training or for field services,
ARCore is a really
good place to start.
ARCore is a library
which does some
of the heavy lifting for you
so you can focus on, really,
the value add
elements of your app.
So things like motion
tracking, detecting
surfaces, which you can then
place objects on virtually,
or light estimation so
you can really make sure
that your objects are
rendered appropriately
for the environment
that you're looking at.
All of that is
taken care for you
so you don't have to worry
about the details, challenges
with some of the sensors.
Machine learning, obviously
a huge topic here at Next
this week.
But Android supports
a whole stack
of different capabilities.
So at the bottom
of the stack here,
you've got the
Neural Networks API.
So that's a native
API on Android
that really helps
you figure out which
is the most optimal hardware
to use for your inference
and for your learning.
So if all you've got is a CPU,
then it will default to that,
all the way up to some
of the latest devices
have TPUs built into them.
And of course,
Neural Networks API
will make sure that those
fastest hardware is used.
TensorFlow Lite then
abstracts that a bit further,
and you can build neural
nets very quickly,
with just a few lines of code.
All the way up to ML
Kit, which enables
you to do your
learning in the cloud,
compress that neural
network model,
and then deploy it to
devices for inference very,
very quickly.
Devices like here, the
Huawei P20 have already
got that TPU chip
built in, and here
you can see a performance
improvement of 10x.
So a tenth of the time
taken to do a neural network
inference using this product.
So there are really
huge advancements
taking place across the
Android ecosystem there.
And then another thing,
I already mentioned IoT,
but Android Things went
[INAUDIBLE] earlier this year,
and a huge opportunity
for enterprises
to leverage the same
technologies that we've built,
whether that's from
the security side,
so making sure you've got things
that hardware root of trust,
and all the encryption key
support, all the way up
to the connectivity options
and the management support
that you need.
So just then to
conclude, I really
encourage you, when you're
thinking about mobile devices
and endpoints in general, think
beyond the knowledge worker
situation or scenario of, like,
devices in people's pockets,
and think about what are
the opportunities you have
to improve your
employee workflows
or even end customer
experiences,
whether that's in a
retail store or elsewhere.
Take a look at the Android
Enterprise Recommended program.
If you are in the
process or soon
to be looking at what
devices to purchase,
Android Enterprise
Recommended can give you
a really good sense of
what are the devices that
meet some of those critical
enterprise requirements,
and also what are those--
could you leverage that for
curating the set of devices
that you support within a BYOD.
And then finally, when you're
purchasing your devices,
make sure that you're doing that
through a zero touch enabled
reseller, because as
you're purchasing them,
then that reseller will be able
to mark those in the zero touch
system that are owned
by you, and then
you can benefit from that
really frictionless approach
to enrolling devices when
they're deployed to users.
And then finally, take
a look at Android P.
There's now eight different
device manufacturers
that support that, so
really great opportunity now
to get that into your test labs
and see what the opportunities
are that that brings.
So with that, just
to close, here's
a quick summary of the other
sessions going on about Android
Enterprise this week.
Feel free to take a photo.
The only one I haven't
mentioned is the last one,
using mobile as a catalyst
for digital transformation.
My colleague Sean-- sorry,
I will get out of the way,
then you can take a photo--
my colleague Sean is going to be
talking through a bit more high
level around like
how can you apply
Android and its technologies
to really transform businesses.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]